matal has never looked at a woman even
in any parts of her body well um
wouldn't go that far so anyway you
having sex like
this just like this watching NCIS NCIS
and then a woman comes on the screen you
go like
this I I need to C back you
on
Runk hello hello
hello hello will
hello
hello hello how many I do you want
that's not a question you want Light Ice
you want no ice or extra IES yeah Light
extra ice extra ice you want extra IES
so there going to ask you yeah that's
crazy they even dude always the most ice
Light Ice is weird I like no ice cuz I
then I put my own and well that's
different that's fine that's fine that's
that's fine that's I like I like to uh
have no ice cuz then I can add my own
ice yay yay that's the most boring thing
you could possibly say I think well I
don't agree dude how about the fact that
it's Christmas Eve just hear those
sleigh bells wringling Jing Jing
jingling
too lovely weather for you blind you
look so blind in those glasses it's
blind dude you know what I look blind in
these glasses and these and this grower
dieye hoodie which is awesome it's grow
actually talk about while can you zoom
in Anthony could you in the edit zoom in
it's absolutely embroidered
it is embroidered grow or die people do
not understand that I'm not religious
and they say you shouldn't have God on
there but he's you know he's
controversial he's always been
controversial the sword it says grower
do look at that you zoom in on there um
so it's at chris.com it's the best merch
we ever did and it's uh cold so get it
and it's Christmas Eve so you can
actually get it now and be like yo I got
you this tomorrow on Christmas when you
see someone so there you go uh but
anyway that's terrific do people really
get mad about God oh of course that's so
dumb dude of course of course God people
well I mean I have stop getting upset at
stuff that affects your life zero MH yay
Matt y Bravo Mato mat yay we love you
dude throwing flowers um so and then
also I'll tell you what's been really
kicking and what you can do is go to
patreon.com Lifeline luxury holy Franken
I'll tell you what the last couple yeah
holy Franken binkin Anthony
blinkin it's crazy little bit it's crazy
crazy good all yeah and it's it's it's
pretty good and so you could go get that
fill up your stocking with the
patreon.com lifeline luxury and then I
have a a new I've have new dates on on
sale uh Sacramento Brea California
Phoenix El Paso uh Albuquerque and then
we got Kona is that how you say it this
BC Vancouver BC uh Rochester New York uh
kitner Ontario shreport Louisiana
Houston Texas wow there's a lot here
Corpus Christie which I've never been to
Durham which I love and norfol I think
that's how you say it
norfol norfol Virginia so that's you go
to chris.com and get him up while
they're still hot while they're still
there you get the good seats uh that's
it do you want the good seats go now and
buy them now okay you want the regular
seats yeah maybe wait a day Matt's got
his pod go to uh go to go to the
private.com submit you and your story to
be a guest on my soon to be enormously
famous podcast the private record
theprivate record.com follow us on
Instagram and Tik subscribe on YouTube
CH chill right chill chill chill so uh
send us a submission link is uh below
and uh that's what's up now it's
Christmas coming up tomorrow so it might
be Christmas today you're listening to
this uh watching this on Christmas you
could be avoiding your family listening
to or watching this right now so if it
is all I can say is Merry Christmas and
uh you know what I actually don't
like I don't
like what what's up with ho ho ho you
know like that's not how people laugh
that's not what Sans is doing man
Santa's ho ho ho is a completely
singular thing unto itself he's not
laughing really Santa have you always
thought Santa was laughing when he says
ho ho ho yes you have the weirdest brain
well why is he just ever developed by a
human ho like he's an orgy that's like
what he says like come like come one
come all it's like his expression
whatever ho ho ho and he comes down the
chimney with his fat [__] fat [__]
too early to swear you know what I think
he is laughing oh smashed you think that
or you know that cuz he does go like
this a lot of go ho ho they do like that
cuz he's Jolly dude but Jolly is on the
way to laughing it is but it's not is
that it isn't look look it up I thought
it was laughing yeah ho ha what if it
was that that's then he would be
laughing then he'd be me uh I don't know
but what I if it was ha haa he would be
laughing if it's he he he he would be me
if it's ho ho ho it's just it's just
Santa he's Express his immense happiness
with boisterous laughter Oh god well
that's just Google that's Santa letter
factory okay that's not a reputable
Source but you know what let me just say
this Google only shows you what it wants
to show you goog Google is the
government dude late last night my
brother texted this thread the lifeline
thread which is me and him obviously and
then Chris and Anthony behind the
cameras and he just all out of the blue
texted Google is the
government right appros nothing AO
nothing just a just an idiot down a
rabbit hole of Idi of of like idiotic
links you know it probably is but but
think about this though like who used
clicked on one outbrain link on the
bottom of some like page and then
clicked on another link after the
outbrain one and ended up thinking the
Google is the government okay so so
check this out the government's in
control right okay all right cool all
right okay cool fine sounds good how
about this bureaucratic government
agencies yes they're control of okay
sounds good okay cool hey yeah okay give
us the rules government okay so check
this out
dude who hey fentura
dude Ace Ventura wow
dude oh oh does the government have
their own search engine oh or do they
use Google oh so Google so everybody
uses Google oh so everybody could type
in anything on Google and get a
pre-planned uh biased uh list of things
that they're looking up and oh and also
the government does that so oh oh so
Google is in control of everything
because if the government wants to
Google something Oh Google's the one
that puts out the bias list and now oh
the officials in the government check
that list and then oh they're shipping
Society so oh it's not necessarily the
government that shipping Society oh it's
Google so Google's the government thank
you very much Merry Christmas ho ho ho
Google's the government dude the wise
ass thing you're doing
oh it only makes the argument you're
making that much more annoying and
idiotic
imagine imagine a lawyer did it or like
in Congress people were doing it I mean
I guarantee you someone's done that yeah
congressmen and women like when they
take the mic on the like at some kind of
session they're such
like righteous Yeah ironic [__] oh
so I take that what I take that to mean
is you hate America and that's what
you're saying isn't it yeah and then the
person has like 12 seconds to respond
why yeah why is that why are the mics so
bad in Congress too you know it's always
like they don't know how to use them cuz
they're just some dentists and then
they're 56 and get elected and then
they're sitting in front of a mic and
don't know what to do stripping
stripping that is a good hoodie though
you should buy that everybody so so some
dentist you know um that's what these
people are dude I know I'm just saying
I'm just saying okay don't get me don't
get me started I almost got started but
I stopped okay that's but what I'm
saying is the that Google shapes our
world more than you know it I think it
shapes our world a whole lot okay but
more than you know it Google is the no
well maybe yeah Google is the government
because Google is in control of the
government because it's biased and it
can sway anything election oh check
please but when you say in control of
the government what do you what do you
even mean the government uses Google
that's why I only use what does that
mean the government use got use Bing
more what what does that mean the
government uses Google dude like what
are you saying when
government okay look
Google did you ever see the thing where
they Google uh uh something like uh top
or something uh Republican
races uh winner races winner whatever
and it says like and and the first
suggestion is Republican racist quotes
and it's like oh dude we're getting
shaped have you read that book I mean
probably have you read that book about
what what is I got to look it about the
gam I read it I read it let me let me
find the title that's the thing it's
like Google can just basically shape us
dude and they could sway the election
they can really sway a lot of they've
done control tests and all this stuff
about the we need more you know we need
more search engines that are they have a
monopoly Google and Facebook they have a
monopoly on this thing that we need more
social networks and we need more search
engines okay you're being a crazy guy
this is why I use lyos
only an ad sponsored by lyos you know no
but that's why we got to use Bing more
but I'm just saying um oh it's called
everybody lies it's about what people
really search on Google and the reason
why certain searches are are uh
suggested is because what people
actually Google is not at all what they
purport to think out in the world sure
and think certainly think about out out
in the world yeah okay so they're saying
that and there's all these studies in
the book that's like they have Google
analytic information which I think is
accessible to everybody right Google
dashboard has like all this information
I mean so they claim dude oh so
skeptical theya just watch planemic you
know no but I'm just saying I mean bleep
that I don't want to get you know I've
seen it but I've also seen Z but I what
have you seen Loose Change Loose Change
was like the first I know like idiot
person thing that that people were like
oh have you seen it it was an inside job
but okay so hold on a second though uh
I remember eating that up by the way
dude me too but that's people are dumb
no no no I never no wait hold on you
didn't watch it and then think that 911
was an inside job I watched loose change
and and and thought something was fishy
about 911 which is but something is
fishy about 911 no it's not the most
clearcut thing ever but we don't know
the whole truth there's no way no way
what do you mean when you say we don't
know the whole truth about everything
it's all there are very weird things
that happened on if you mean like Saudi
Arabia's links to the terrorists sure I
know we don't know and we might not ever
know but if we're talking about what
happened on that day we have a really
really really good idea Bush knocked
down the towers you know that's that rap
song by Immortal Technique it was you it
was you Bush knock Bush knocked down
them Towers wow that is it was you the
definition of ignorant you know well
didn't knock down the towers the bush
have long-standing ties with very very
weird families if anybody sure and
they're corrupt as FR that's what I'm
saying they're corrupt as fros but that
doesn't mean that they there was an
inside job con I'm not saying that
George Bush was like well knock down the
towers if you need proof that there was
no connection just look at his reaction
to learning that it happened he's too
the fact that you could think that he
could control anything is crazy he's
just always like what yeah yeah so you
know he would he didn't orchestrate this
but I'm saying just look at his
paintings there's a good glimpse into
his mind and his uh but anyway this is
really great Christmas talk but Merry
Christmas and uh the Google's in control
of the government and so mer
and um I hope quarterback I hope it's
great dude Merry Christmas I hope that
everyone had a good Christmas I hope
everyone is having a good Christmas and
I hope that uh the Hanukkah Hanukkah was
good I hope that K Quanza will be good
and boxing day and all that all of the
holidays that you can celebrate I hope
all of you that are celebrating each one
of those are having the greatest one
you've ever had yeah it's been a rough
year for a lot of people but it's time
to celebrate and get happy for the onc
coming year okay that hasn't come yet
might be amazing okay okay what about
the Christmas the next year might be am
oh yeah I know I know I know but then
it's like it won't because there's an
election right well it won't be because
it's just a year and every year is
similar to the year before generally
speaking and years are bad okay let be
positive though yeah no next year's
going to be
great let's start all right let's start
we know him yeah we do yo what's up man
what's up Chris what's up I'm going to
get right to it who's this guy again I
have got a very unique situation on my
hands guess we don't know him I am a bit
befuddled with how to move forward okay
so I've recently started dating this
girl we're both around 30 years old okay
it's been going really great um but this
past week I've learned some unique
information about
her I don't know if it's a red flag or
not so so she has multiple friends who
are much older men oh okay like guys in
their 60s mult how many mult and what
gets even more peculiar is the details
about the relationships of these men so
one older man that she is friends with
is her first boyfriend from high school
his father oh wow so over the past 15
years or so they've stayed in contact
they text he sends her good morning like
there's hearts in the text what he sends
their pictures of his puppy sometimes he
even brings over gifts like wine or Mar
and they hang out I don't want to make
any assumptions or come to any
conclusions very fair of you just want
to present the facts that's happening
that's it's Unique it's yeah that is
certainly unique that that's unique
secondly later next month um she works
in the medical field she's going to be
going to like a Christmas holiday party
with with an older guy from work a
doctor cheats more than people in the
medic 60s yeah and they're going to be
all crashing at another coworker's house
who was in her 20s so it's going to be a
bunch of people in their 20s early 30s
and then old man Bill he's also going to
be like sleeping over so I get what's
going on I thought that was peculiar all
good um so she has these like I get wait
pretty close friendships with much older
men got it another factor I a couple
factors to take
she's
verye CL buddy in her past she has dated
a man that is 20 years older than her
thanks buddy she to older guys or at
least open to the idea of men problem
I'll handle this one so open I'm just
going to leave it there great um please
let me know gotcha what you guys think
about this um I do plan I do like her a
lot she's awesome that's cool F so if I
do want to take this relationship
further I obviously have to address this
I have to bring it up and just learn
more information about it I guess um is
this a red flag is it not how should I
approach it with her um i' love any your
guys thoughts and well you're going to
get them you're going to get about it
hey dude ice out she's a hooker all good
moving on dude hey all good Shing dude
all good all good all good you dating a
lady of the night and it's fine move on
ier out sh hooking it's all good dude
that is crazy you're dating a hooker
congratulations dude nice to meet you oh
where's the woman oh her cool very cool
how much do I have to pay to get my nut
sucked dude she is an absolute hucker
that's insane that is insane if she's
not a hooker which is a very very very
very very small chance her dad died
early and she has huge problems all good
next so next one let's explore just like
for the sake of just doing it let's
explore what our bank account to see if
we could afford
[Laughter]
her let's let's the clinic to see we
text what what should we explore very
slow small chance you as you
said1 she ain't hooking I don't think
it's as simple as she's a hooker I
actually don't a h first of all what do
you mean when you you don't think she's
an actual hooker right I think that
there's a chance she could be an actual
hooker but what do you think is more
likely he's probably giving her gifts
and and money and and she's letting them
slide in you oh so you actually think
that she's giving him not just like it
might it might just be attention and and
playfulness and flirting but either way
that's kind of hook and and it's on a I
wanted to go with it okay so so it's
very possible they're not actually
having any sex or or there's nothing
being exch is extremely possible that
that's there's nothing being explicitly
exchanged in terms of materials besides
from the older men to her I'm saying
there's maybe there's actually I would
say a pretty good chance that she's not
actually giving back anything
aile to
basow it to that
being let's here's here's what I want to
say let's just say all of it is as
innocent as can be the party thing the
coworker let's just say all that is as
as as innocent as possible
Right the thing about the ex-boyfriend's
dad mhm yeah is so
so so weird Over The Line
that it doesn't matter what's going on
under it like what I'm saying is it
doesn't matter if she's actually
explicitly selling herself for something
namely sex or if she's just like we
really get along and ever since my
boyfriend and I broke up we've grown
closer to the point that now he's just
like sends me good morning texts with
hearts and comes over every once in a
while that's just so weird and dude I
get it I so get when you're so into a
girl at the beginning that you're trying
to see like it because when you hang out
with her she's normal she's fun she's
funny she's sweet she gets things that
you get she likes things that you like I
get it dude but just trust me and him
even though you shouldn't always trust
him in this instance it's fair to do
that he or she's something's weird it's
a crazy red something is too weird and
if your question is is it a red flag
fine that's how many red flags are is
such a big red flag yeah yeah okay oh
dude
you don't even need to know like you
don't even need to know County Fair
what's going on under it it doesn't
matter the surface is weird enough hey
do we keep entering China because there
are so many red flags I keep seeing am I
am I walking in and out of China over
and over again because I keep seeing a
red flag yeah are you president XI
jingpin of China at a rally for himself
are you president xiin pin because if
because it seems like SE Shan pen we are
because X Shan
[Laughter]
pen ah yeah are you president Shan Shan
Paul and for all those people that are
like oh I don't like that he fun of G
name what's that
President I don't president Sean Shan
Paul [__] Paul's a a regga
guy oh got it dude [__] absolutely
wake up with her and
go or you're a red flag dude no or just
say hey that's so weird like I need you
to know how weird this is it's not just
me who thinks it it's also Matt and
Chris deia the only yeah the only one
who doesn't think it's weird is sea P
Sean uh Paul
dude that is absolutely nuts bro that's
pretty nuts and it's a your question is
is it a red flag yes it's a red flag she
may not be hooking obviously I'm the one
who's going to be making
I honestly don't think that that is that
indicates she's a hooker no I know but
but my whole thing is if you
okay I I use the term hooker Loosely
because because to me though it's you're
still kind of a hooker if that's what
you're doing I that's why I asked you to
specify cuz I I knew you didn't mean a
prostitute but but but like it's like
when you like what is a porn star people
are like oh porn star is people who have
sex on on on PornHub or whatever
to me a porn star is like if you're on
Instagram doing this like and your
nipples peeking out you're a porn star
well no I thought you going to say the
other way a porn star is someone who's
famous for doing porn someone who works
in the adult the star thing is what
where I'm losing you I'm just say you do
porn if you show your nipples I don't
give a [__] and you know you could call
me old or whatever the [__] but like
yeah I think that would classify you as
oldfashioned yeah but and and and do
what you want this is great I think more
people should show their nipples but
don't act like you don't do porn that's
what a pornographic image is sure so
there you go I mean you got people
busting It Wide Open and they're acting
like it's not they're like no I
sing huh e the porn who sings I don't
know I'm just saying only fans people
are like check out my new album and
stuff well we live in a world where you
know people do all these different
things F like real actresses do have
only fans now I'm a comedian weird that
I know but I'm a comedian I'm also a
conspiracy theorist you could be a lot
of different things you know dude I know
I have a podcast I'm also a writer I've
been that for many many years but also
I'm basically like Tony Robbins I'm I'm
Tony Robbins 2.0 I just I just my whole
thing is that's a huge red flag it's
very weird um you know there there's
nothing wrong with it if you know what's
going on and she is coping to it but I
she probably doesn't even know why she's
doing it dude you got to break it you
got to up person you got to break it
down real get real with her and just say
look I understand that you have this
perspective that you think it's normal
but let's just talk it all the way
through cuz I really want you to
understand where I'm coming from about
how weird this is okay and then have
that conversation it's not it's not like
you need to Nix her out of your life no
right right if you have the conversation
she's like oh wait I get it or I
understand what you're saying and it's
worth it to me because you think it's so
weird for me to stop whatever like
there's a number of ways this can go
with that include you remaining her
boyfriend or whatever stage you're at
with her you know yeah and I I also I
don't know man I
mean it's
just does I I would like here's for me I
would like her like if I was if this was
happening to me right I would I would be
like it's important for me
to it's important to me that you know
that these guys want to have sex with
you I want you to know I because if the
second she's like no I don't think it's
like that you you're either with an
idiot or a
bullshitter and then it's like I can't
have that kind of person around me yeah
you know and that whole argument of was
like well you think that all I have to
offer is sex and it's like of course not
no but to a 60-year-old man and yeah
yeah yeah I mean you know what are you
going to sit and talk about right I mean
of well that's just like strawmanning
the the thing you're bringing to her if
you bring it that to her and she says
what do you think all I'm good for is
sex he like well OB no not that's not at
all what I'm saying I'm saying what
these guys we can't ignore the braa
right we can't ignore the boy y Yoo
right you know what I'm saying developed
a stutter and keeps stuttering on this
one word that you're trying to say we
can't we cannot ignore
the develop stut develop the stutter we
cannot ignore the boy devel the stutter
we cannot dude okay okay nextway next
I mean read this wait hold on hey Chris
hey Matt I had to type because my
younger brother and his 18-year-old
girlfriend flat next door but I would
agree eye contact longer than 3 seconds
over a span of several times has to give
the impression you're physically
attracted to somehow to someone I have
caught her promiscuously dead pants
staring multiple times I look at her
like she's my sister but she's also hot
respectably I don't know if I should
tell my brother what could I
D this is just a video it looks like
it's a 1993 wow and uh he's saying he
put old on it yeah well it actually also
says it but yeah is this from n 3 no so
but that that this is hilarious so okay
so he has a younger brother who has his
an 18-year-old girlfriend who he thinks
of as his sister he couldn't say this
cuz on the video they're right next to
him right
but he the guy's face looks at him just
like this with eyes that
imply attraction undressing or sexual
like like hope hopeful for sexual
activity right uh what was his question
what does he do well here's the thing I
know what you
do nothing yeah the most ha nothing
there is no I think that so if you look
at somebody for more than 3
seconds if there in a coffee shop or a
stranger you're attracted to them but if
it's somebody you're in a room with and
it's your brother's girlfriend sometimes
you need to look at somebody for longer
than 3 seconds like I look at every
person in this room for much longer than
3 seconds that doesn't mean anything
besides I have respect for them what you
like what are you maybe this guy just
has she has respect everyone you know
look at the ground when they talk to you
like what are you talking about when
people look at people that means they're
either listening or just paying
attention like what are you what people
look at people no but staring at him she
sneaking looks he said three seconds
though is what he said he's saying over
three seconds but yeah cuz we we talked
about but so but okay so what's three
seconds so let's look at this so let's
take this camera right here so this is
me looking at somebody for 3 seconds
ready okay right okay you can ready go
ahead and
now that was 3 seconds I mean that's
pretty uncomfortable if you're staring
at somebody for that long and like if
they see you staring don't look away
yeah and they're not talking let me do
it you count it I'll okay yeah I'm going
to count out loud though ready okay go
ahead do whenever no 1 2 3 yeah it's
pretty weird it's uncomfortable yeah
well but does it it doesn't mean longer
than that it doesn't mean anything
though what I'm saying I looked at a
person oh we look at the camera dude why
am I doing that okay fine okay okay
ready go ready ready go ready and go one
two three it's
uncomfortable uh I wanted people to know
because they're looking at you now let
me do it again again again one two I
mean that would be so weird wa R&B cover
you know two of them yeah um that's
inside flap so
but yeah I I just I think it's an
uncomfortable thing to do to a stranger
if you're doing to a stranger for sure
if you're single and
you're out you know and a a woman is
looking at you or a man is looking at
you for three more than three seconds
that's your I would say that
that's kind of an open invitation to hey
what's up I would say stranger sure yeah
stranger right again again this is
someone who knows her by his own words
very well well that's what I'm saying so
it may just be her it may be nothing it
may be nothing I mean people are crazy
maybe she does have a weird thing that
she wants to I agree it may be nothing
and therefore because of the situation
that it is because it may be nothing you
have to act and and actually believe
something cuz to believe let alone act
but to believe otherwise is to cause
such problems Havoc like what Havoc to
cause Havoc so much and why bother like
why would you start that you need
someone to be like hey I have
intense irrepressible feelings for you
to like which dealt with a lot of times
a lot of people say that to me no and
it's it's you know it's
at some point it's Mo in my 30s people
would say that to me because I was
really strapping uh it was most of my
day I was dealing with that question no
okay never happened uh but yeah crazy
intense feelings about you everyone sit
down you know I get them all together a
lot of guys I know always think so this
is common guys so and so likes them like
some girl can they can tell and it's
just like you know why right biology
guys have to think that okay but I know
that but it's it and I said it it would
be better if those guys also believed
people look at people bad for biology
because
they're around that is for procreation
of the human race sure but like you need
wants me hey what's up you don't need to
think that baby comes out right you
don't need to think that now the human
RAC is people look at people the end bye
next I think what I like about this guy
the most is that he said I would agree
before saying the thing about looking at
you for 3 seconds yes just starting a
new thought with I would agree that is
what he did yeah well was it again I
would agree that looking at somebody for
3 seconds longer means that they want to
oh right I have it in my head nobody
[__] said I have it I have it in my
head that we've talked about that in
this on this show before Oh really think
we have yeah and and if we haven't
that's an awesome conversational tactic
to use you know what I would agree that
you've been a dick last week but I would
like to say people like wait wait wait
did I say that yeah it's a really good
debate stry great great that's great I'm
not use that thank you very much uh
Elvis so all right I was going to say
that I know and and and I'm shocked you
didn't why didn't you can't say
everything can't say I can't say
everything that comes into your mind no
no I know but it's funny I'll let you do
it do you agree it's funny but did you
but it's not it's not as funny if I have
to do it here's what if it was just me
and you I would have said it I don't
know if enough people know thank you
very much is associated I think you have
a piece of lint in your in your hair
going to pull a prank on me dog [__]
smear dog [__]
okay uh all right Co next
one hi Chris hi Matt uh my name is
Britney I I live in San Jose California
and I am in love with both of you so
much you're so funny you really just
made me happy in times where I didn't
want to be happy yeah anyway it's
Christmas time great and I'm really
stressed out I don't have a ton of money
to spend on presents and I feel
obligated to get everyone a present like
he it like you know my two close friends
my boyfriend his mom his dad his sister
his sister's boyfriend like okay I I
have I have something I'm just stressed
out and I I don't have racks on racks on
racks um and I'm not a grinch like I
love Christmas and I loveing it's just
this time of year stresses me the F out
so and I'm not creative like I I like I
can't really make anything but I'm
wondering how how do I get inexpensive
gifts like that don't like I got them
from the dollar store and that aren't
like super impersonal um any advice will
help that dog is hilarious so I don't
have to give my dog away like I don't
want to I don't want to give my dog away
because I can't afford him you know dog
is a shadow did does that dog want to
[__] me and staring at me for longer
than 3 seconds um I I well first of all
let me take something off your your back
here I think that if your boyfriend's
family he deals with that I don't think
you have to worry about that you that's
on him you know like well if they're
going to be get everyone in the if is
going to get her something I get it I I
I think it's still on him get meaning
what meaning it's up to him to to like
if if Kristen was like what do I get
your dad I say this oh I see what you're
saying yeah and then I obviously I pay
for it so on him you mean oh okay well
there you go okay so you do mean he not
only thinks of it but he pays for it I
think so okay if it's his family here's
the thing and this is the most important
thing this goes honestly for everybody
who celebrates Christmas and has people
to get gifts for who get gifts for them
and they feel like they don't know if
the person that you're giving a gift to
actually gets upset or even slightly
bothered by the fact that you didn't
spend a lot of money on
them as a on a Christmas gift and these
people are adults yeah those people
those those people suck yeah it's crazy
okay that's crazy you don't suck for not
having enough money to get expensive
gifts to them they suck for being like
why didn't this person who doesn't have
a lot of money spend it a lot a lot of
it on me okay so that alone should that
fact should remove some of the stress on
you you don't it's and I it's not just
like I mean I know it's tired to say
like it's the thought that counts you
got to get a gift anyway for some people
so it's not like it's not your thought
it's the holiday that makes you get a
gift for them but like something
thoughtful from person to person someone
that that per it's like either there's a
a joke that you guys have had for a
while or like something you know someone
else is interested in you get them a
book on that or whatever it is like
these things are cheap just think about
the person and then get the gift
accordingly you don't need to think well
what's a great gift to get for somebody
these people are all individual people
that you have individual relationships
with get them something that it can be
literally under $5 but that is just even
if it's it's just like
a because it and those kinds of things
bring you closer it's not about money if
you're like an ad adult if you're an
adult and it's about money the Christmas
gifts you get from other people like you
got something wrong with you straight up
make them a Sund dial make him a Sund
dial and that's my point make him a Sund
dial it's super easy you don't have to
be creative just put a stick on a piece
of wood and be like look it's 2
o' you tell cuz the sun well we got to
go outside but M it only works outside
it's raining ah [__] it uh I should play
something I bet Sund dials are harder to
make than we realize so maybe not I just
use my penis I go outside yeah I I I I I
lay down I start thinking of my wife and
then and then once I I'm completely
thinking of her it's completely straight
up and that's when I oh I see right
right okay yeah okay I go like this I'm
outside if I'm if I'm outside at night
it doesn't go if I'm outside in the
daytime in the backyard and I'm and you
see me naked on the ground going my wife
my wife my wife my wife I'm trying to
tell the time oh that what you're doing
yeah oh I've I've seen I'm trying to
find out what time it is yeah oh what
time is it oh hold on one
second my wife my wife my wife me I'm
just like my wife4 my wife my wife I
think it's 2:30 but I can't talk because
of the hair um so dumb you
know
uh yeah mhm don't I understand cuz I
stress too but like you got to you got
to always remind yourself
if these people are my point is they're
not thinking that way they're not
thinking how much money this person
spend on
me unless you're peace unless what
unless you're peace what does that mean
piece of [__] oh right exactly that's my
point
andum [__] girlfriend hanging out
with a 60-year-old right yeah what' you
get me hey let's all sleep over the
house yeah yeah you sleep in the bed too
you're 60 okay cool what's
this the more I think about that the
weirder it is actually yes so weird dude
hey what's all this oh hey look at
that oh that's what that is dude it
sounded like you were a monster eating
someone dude I saw Tim Allen the other
day driving by not even at a comedy club
did he go like this no I was driving by
he was walking out of a Starbucks and
let me tell you something about Tim
Allen that dude looks [__] great he's
70 years old and the guy looked topnotch
I guess money but like money is helpful
in this yeah but I mean the guy just
looked great he's in good shape it's
messed up but it's true a lot of people
in Hollywood just look yeah they age
better now let me so and that's money I
guess okay so I'm 43 I I I guess I I I
look good for 43 I think you know like
if you if you see a guy that's just 43
chances are he's going to be fat and
pink you know what I'm saying but like
but like I don't do anything
except you work out like crazy right but
that's not money okay right so so it's I
don't there's no no
monetary I don't use money for anything
to keep me looking young like I don't
have face creams I don't have any sort
of regimen I take a shower I use Dove
soap I work out and I eat I mean that's
that's true of D I mean Dad into his 70s
looked always like 15 years younger than
people his age that's true of him too
true yeah I guess so so some people just
age better but then there are people
like if you look at like if you look at
Cameron Diaz she hasn't had much work
done she looks [__] amazing you look
at Julia Roberts she hasn't yeah she
hasn't had much work done she looks
[__] amazing oh I bet you Julia
Roberts has had plenty of work done
right some but I bet she's but but I'm
telling you a lot of these people look
like they haven't had work done that's
because they've had such good work done
okay so that there's that but then there
are also those Beverly Hills out people
that just look so terrible yeah like
Nicole Kidman yeah right so she's got
the same money as J Roberts sometimes
your face doesn't react the right it's
just like you know all right uh all
right I don't understand with with s
specifically the fact that they do so
much work to their face almost
inevitably makes their face more Frozen
harder to move that is literally the the
only thing that matters as an actor well
subtlety that what did your face like
you can't freeze that up you can't make
your one tool that you
need less good how weird is it that they
do that they do uh like they'll do like
they'll get lip injections and then
cheek fillers and then a chin and then
like they'll they'll do a movie about
like Julia Caesar and you're like oh
they had work back then look at her
titties are like so fake and she she got
a BBL and she's like sa the hell's a BBL
Brazilian buttlift oh man but that ah
why does that gross me out you know what
cuz you have to sit on it yeah it's like
so makes me so uncomfortable sit on it
what's that alucino
thing what right what is that though
what's it from I I don't
remember it was on the soundboard right
right was it sound and you s on it was
that just from an impression you did oh
it might have been from my impression I
did yeah but anyway
um uh that's the thing about the
Brazilian buttlift is is that it's
disgusting no it is is that is that it's
disgusting but no put intended
um they're getting real good at it what
does that mean they docs oh and you
don't
know sometimes I you know what's I mean
I'm I'm like the worst person to talked
about this cuz I don't even look at
butts really on women yeah women I don't
look at butts on women yeah really yeah
okay now let me ask you a question
what's wrong with
you I don't know I don't know I can't
answer that cuz I I I'm me and I don't I
don't know that's interesting isn't that
amazing so what's wrong with that what's
wrong with you I don't I I I don't look
at butts so your beta Mayo no that's not
what that means beta Mayo I look at
other things like
penises no other things you I'm doing
right no I don't what's his name Jesse
Lee Peterson oh that guy oh dude yeah
you must not be doing a great impression
doing a great impression no that's this
is what he says yeah oh that's amazing I
know I know I knew that better than you
so it's okay but I did that dude it's
okay thank you so um hold on
uh you don't look at butts I I mean
obviously of course I know I know I
don't peep them like you you you never
do a lean here's what I never do when a
woman walks by mhm really D I've never
done that in my life dude yeah what yeah
I I just Nei what what I do is I I walk
back I trop backwards to stay looking at
the front of them oh wow that's really
creepy yeah yeah yeah it is eyes eyes
eyes eyes up
eyes up here up here so um yeah wow I
I'm not even legs they're not what I
don't know what zero like like nothing
no no tits no face no I'm gay in fact I
don't even look at women I just look
right their head I look at the sidewalks
uh dude this is crazy no I'm like uh a
waste up person yeah much more than men
than I think most men yeah oh wow yeah
so not like black guys what about black
guys they love Butts oh they do yeah you
could honestly your face could look like
an an
armoir a as long as you got a back on it
I guess black dudes really do love
a bunny yeah hey hey look at that that's
coyote that's wild coyote I know but I
mean different cartoons Looney Tunes but
like you know there's a connection to
them and all um yeah that's uh really
wild one time I was walking I'll never
forget this it was in Sacramento which I
will be in January so get to get a
crystal.com but I was in Sacramento and
I was walking with who who was I walking
with I don't remember who was featuring
for me at the time but I was walking
down the
street a woman walked by and I I I guess
I I I look back she was pretty I looked
back at her to see her whole thing you
know cuz I don't judge a book just by
its cover I go to the back cover too and
what a good guy and uh I want to see who
wrote it you know who wrote it and um
that is the worst poem now don't ruin it
because people aren't going to know what
you're doing I've ever heard him Al but
people aren't going to know what you're
doing and you're ruining what I'm doing
right now right so you're taking it and
you're steering it away and that's an
inside joke that we have that some might
know I ruined two things it's okay yeah
I'm just counting okay so so I look to
see who wrote the book and another woman
walking this way says seriously you're
[__] disgusting wow and I say get the
[__] give me a break okay that's
it that didn't go where I thought it
might go yeah fine I'm where I thought
that would that's a good a good story
tell yeah so wait what did she say again
exactly she says oh you're disgusting
are you serious you're disgusting
disgusting it's not disgusting you're
disgusting for different reasons well in
my headed to be right but it was not for
that in my head I'm like all men do this
but you don't then I don't do that oh my
God mat Leah wouldn't do
that no I really don't mat is a waste up
guy yeah it's just m would jog backwards
and stay focused on on the front of her
mat has never looked at a woman even in
any parts of her body well um wouldn't
go that far so anyway you having sex
like this
just like this watching NCIS NCIS and
then a woman comes on the screen and go
like
just I need got bacula on wow that's
NCIS New Orleans not just NCIS such a
fraking dork you know so it's all good
all right who's up
okay hey Chris hey Matt Anthony you're
from Las Vegas I have a pretty big issue
I'm hoping you guys can help me with uh
regular people using military time
I work in the at a local hospital and
for whatever reason they love to use
military time instead of the standard
regular normal human time my real issue
with this is like when we clock out for
lunch or anything like it pops up in
military time and at the end of each pay
period we have to confirm the hours
we've worked in military time which
means I have to do math to figure out if
my hours are correct M for one failed
math every year ever for two two shaa
cuz I didn't enlist in the military for
three alra calculus isn't in my job
description I just find it to be
ridiculous and downright Bonkers for all
I care they might as well change the
time format to Roman numerals because it
would be just as difficult to figure out
he's literally reading I literally have
to look up a military time converter
every week just to ensure my paycheck
isn't missing any hours wouldn't make it
D also why the F do they just add a zero
in front of the actual time in the am
02843 6 38 [__] doesn't make sense to me
anyways I'm done ranting about numbers
what should I do should I just quit my
job Jo the military or just put up with
it and hope one day every comes to their
senses and goes back to standard timing
cut in the front of the car thanks guys
love you both okay okay why did he write
it now he was probably just oh look
first try
that's oh good well at Le hilarious yeah
okay good good good I went from being
like what's with this guy now I like him
again what you say at the end first try
something like that
yeah the greatest guy in the world funny
never SE never ever G look like a
[__] piece of [__] um wait Mother
Teresa who how what's he what's this
[__] guy talking about
calculus it's so easy it's very easy but
what it's not comp it's not like it's
written in Chinese digits yeah what do
you what it's so easy dude it's very
easy but I will say this also get used
to it you don't need to know he he said
calculus number three I don't know
calculus you don't need to know calculus
you need to know simple addition and
subtraction the reason why people do it
is cu it's less confusing yes exactly
yeah but it ends up being more confused
because no one does it right people are
more used to just telling time the way
the clock tells medical field or an army
time you need to be very precise so you
don't to say hey we're going to bomb
someone at five at 5:00 a.m. you kill
all the civilians like I meant [__] I
meant when the sun's going down you know
also yeah 5:00
p.m. right it's like they're both
mouthfuls so who gives a [__] also you
can say all of them in less than 1
second so it's fine across the board I
this guy's got a gripe that is a non-
gripe I'm sorry is it annoying like
maybe a little bit but dude get over it
and what does he do as a job he works at
some hospital I don't know so he works
at a place where they use it that's what
he's that's why he's complaining so you
have to use it that's why what do you
mean that's that's I'm saying don't so
so don't be annoyed at it he thinks
there's some math involved like it well
what you do is to make it easy is you
say oh uh you know 20:00 or whatever you
you got to subtract two and then take
the one off it's eight but also it's so
easy right I know I know I understand
1300 hours isor 1 p.m. or memorize it
yeah cuz you
take 2 and you take that it's so easy
and you take the one off take one off
his first point was well I've never been
good at math you don't [__] need to
be oh then this is just for
you you never good at math this is
perfect for you yeah I think that
um yeah I I think that you got to just
get used to it uh and that's very it's
very easy it's actually very easy and I
do know somebody that's very close to me
that uses army time all only is that
right yep and were they are they
ex-military no okay I don't know why the
hell she does it actually she used to be
a flight attendant maybe no that's no
that might be why but uh she does it her
phone is on it you know but it's her her
just to spite this [__] but it's
annoying because uh you
know but she'll do it she'll be like
what time is it she'll be like two 2:
p.m. she cuz she sees 14 and then she 2:
p.m. you understand she doesn't say it's
14 o00 to me that would be really
annoying yeah that would be she doesn't
expect others yeah I get it
right you know so I don't
know I guess that's it by way
next hey guys my question in regards to
being a people pleaser oh good um cuz
that's what I am so ultimately I guess
admittedly like deep down obviously
don't want to admit this this but like I
sort of care what people
think and whenever people say that they
don't care what people think I'm always
like you didn't hack The Human Condition
right right exactly I'm very doubtful
this is Mark but okay so
Chris um having gone through what you've
gone through not only recently but I
mean coming up as a
standup I know that it's common for a
standup in your position to have shed
any sort
of uh feeling that's even close to
caring what people think um so for you
what does that actually feel like is it
actually completely absent or is it more
so just the sort of immediacy with which
you process that sort of negative
perception of you appreciate it guys
uh Chris I saw you for like the sixth
time in November um and you killed it
obviously um Peace and Love yeah I guess
I'll just sit this one out cuz it was
only directed at one person and that
person wasn't me it was no it wasn't
great um I think honestly it you I mean
look it's a balance you know I mean I
want people to like me was one of the
reasons why I do it I do but uh you know
stand but
[Music]
um I think that
it's the second I get consumed with oh
what do these people think what is this
what is you know what makes
people do these people like me do they
approve of me do they you know and
they're strangers I I try to and I have
learned and am learning to combat that
with all right the opposite of that is
who matters to me in my life what do
they think of me and what am I grateful
for that's the only thing that somewhat
helps because you know I've been at the
end of a the hate online hate mob you
know for years and years and for and you
know it's either from something I say or
people think that I did something or
whatever it is
and you know ultimately those people
they they don't know me so and for your
for your in situation you're talking
about people that may not know you on a
um Grand scale but the people that do
what do they think of you you seem like
you're a good guy I'm sure you are a
good guy and do you have friends and do
you have family members that love you
that's the stuff that matters because it
has to be that way um it's okay to want
to be cool for people and want to be
handsome or or or or people want you to
think that you you want people to think
that you're smart but ultimately when it
when when the [__] hits the fan and what
is it about you know it's your family
that matters and so I have my family I
have the people that truly know me that
what do they think of me they think I'm
a good guy and that matters to
me you know sorry no it's pretty much it
you're smart enough this guy I forget
his name to know that it's the human
part of the human condition is to care
what people think to a degree if you're
smart enough to know that you should
also be smart enough to know or at least
understand when I say that people are
not wired to care or even know what
people very very very far away from us
think people will never meet people that
we met online this is not something like
that is has been a part of Human
Experience for long enough for us to
have folded in and know how to react to
that so but it's different for you and
and me even to a degree obviously to a
much lesser degree but any one who's
ever in the public eye at all to deal
with the experience of some random
stranger saying what they think about
something you did or posted online or
whatever that's all very different than
caring what people in your life think
about you what people in your life think
about you there's a scale obviously but
generally that does matter because those
people in your life affect your life and
vice versa and like that is more let's
say like that's a better thing for to
care what those people think caring what
random [__] that you'll never
meet in your life literally ever under
any circumstance and their feelings
about you will have no bearing on you or
your life ever under any circumstance
that shit's got to get tuned out that
doesn't matter at all and it's a it's a
[__] like red herring that you see it
or whatever like if you I don't know why
you would think this this dude but like
it's it's all it's just [__] and you
need to be able to get around that and
totally send it through your head out
the other ear like it's nonsense it's
inapplicable to you it doesn't matter at
all but people in your life you're
supposed to care what they think you
can't like be like well I don't I want
to learn how not to care what people
think that's not going to happen nor is
that a good thing you should care what
people in your life think if they're
dead wrong then no matter what their
their their ideas about you won't be
corrected then sure it's okay to not
give a [__] but like we're supposed to
care what people in our lives think of
us m
that's Again part of the human
condition and you know frankly tall no
okay I was with you until the end and
frankly let's be honest bing
bing you know what I'm saying it's just
like one of those things I do think we
should start using Bing a little bit
more because Google controls the
government but um lyos and
Bing speak English Leos is lios still
something what is lyos you know what it
you know it was right don't I search
engine was an early search engine being
is still a thing for sure yeah Bing is
huge hey Bing is a thing especially when
I say bing bang dude Bing should sponsor
sponsor the show so I can plug their
thing and
say and they'll make a bajillion dollar
what must it be like to be a search
engine and not Google you know what do
you mean there's no there's no
experience of being a search engine
you're a search engine and you're not
the one we use but those it's not
there's nothing it's like
congratulations you're a search engine
and you're not Google you I'm saying if
you work for them you oh work for them
okay yeah but it's like what the [__]
you know but Bing is big dude Bing's big
Bing's big yeah I mean sure it's big but
when it comes to search engines it's not
okay name other early search engin
ask AOL Yahoo Yahoo I mean they they
still exist but yeah are these search
engines though no a start as is oh AOL
is Yahoo is though right Yahoo was oh it
was ask Jeeves don't forget about ask
GES that's probably still around did you
forget about ask jees well I yeah what
what' you say ask Chie is probably still
around no probably not really I mean
they probably there's probably something
on their website [__] nobody's using it
you know dude ask Jos is the one I
remember that is funny to me I don't
remember that at all that's fine how do
you spell that l y c o s oh with a c huh
I was thinking like a very Greek thing
Vista was it one Al Vista was one was
exite remember exite vaguely not Vista
is a good name so what Vista alavista Al
Vista is a good name for one Google is
crazy how they won huh better product
control the government
I want to start I want to start a search
engine same so do I I was thinking about
this last night let's do it I was
thinking about this last night that's
why I texted you I was like dude if we
came up with a search is that what you
said I didn't read that that's why I
sent I said Google control the
government I know but you didn't say the
no but that the reason why is cuz I was
like man we should started searching oh
okay probably be really hard though uh
yeah see Google the thing is oh you
think it' be hard to compete with Google
you think that it's the number one thing
in the world Google is the number one
company dude because they here's the
thing they had a search engine and then
they made a browser do you probably
don't even know this they own Chrome and
then what documentary like or like
shitty YouTube thing did you watch
recently it was on Amazon Prime and was
it just like some like self-published
documentary by some random [__] that was
like produced by Amazon like to [__]
oh right right right yeah yeah no it's
actually really good okay called the
creepy line [__] on Google the creepy
line yeah it's about Facebook and Google
and it Jordan Peterson's in it it's just
really good a of course he
is it's really really [__] good dude
I watch the whole thing like this oh oh
it's about how like going like that
corporate hemony Jordan Peterson in it
no it's about it's about how Google is
controls everything and how they the
thing about Google the
worst Mickey Mouse
just Mickey Mouse dude he sounds like
Kermit first of all not Mickey Mouse
let's talk about the trans issue um y yo
so it's um it's it's a great documentary
but it's about how Google started and
then they were like we need to make
money so then they made a search engine
and then they get all of your data and
and you think you're subscribing to a
product but the product my friend is you
oh you just learned that that's
interesting I've known that for eight
years no but I knew it nice dude give me
a pound for that and I saw the creepy
line it's called that's such a bad title
is a bad title but it is a bad title but
when you watch it you're like no this is
what it had to be called dude I just saw
a clip of uh Jordan Peterson recently
and he was asked do you believe in God
and he said well that depends on what
you mean by do and that and that depends
on what you mean by you no and that
depends on what you believe mean by
believe and I was just like this is a is
this a joke that's great that's like a
SAT Live sketch on J is yeah that all
depends on what you mean by you yeah he
said that and the Breath You Take before
you started
speaking that all depends on what I said
before what you said just so doesn't
want to answer you know it all depends
on how the camera crew set up in what
mood they were in
God just doesn't want to Nix out part of
his potential audience you know that's
funny keep nonbelievers and by just not
answering that question ever that all
depends on what you mean about you what
what you mean by do what you mean by you
what do you mean by believe this what he
said that's what he said it's I saw the
clip yeah all right well hilarious
anyway Merry Christmas ho ho oh I'm
laughing and that's obvious uh grow or
die my special is available watch it
with your family uh submit to the
private record uh and get our patreon
for a Christmas gift on somebody
patreon.com Lifeline luxury appreciate
you guys love you Merry Christmas happy
K Quanza happy Hanukkah happy other
stuff bing bing binging
hello
hello hello